[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde
à la une ce soir emmanuel macron frappe
fort sur le séparatisme islamistes le
chef de l'état étaient très attendus
il a mis des mots sur cette menace qui
pèse sur la république des mots et des
actes
une loi sera présenté le 9 décembre
prochain services publics associations
écoles on va revenir dans un instant sur
toutes les mesures annoncées dans notre
grand débat notre grand témoin lui se
bat depuis des années pour la liberté
d'expression et la laïcité le journal
qu'il a dirigé charlie hebdo fête ses 50
ans cette semaine sur fond d'attentats
terroristes on va revenir avec lui sur
le génie de cabu auquel rembobine à sur
lcp consacre un numéro spécial philippe
val est avec nous ce soir et tout comme
tous les vendredis ce sera le bloc notes
avec nos chroniqueurs donald trump
positif au co vide
ce sera avec françois durpaire l'apéro
de camille saféris et bien sûr le coup
de gueule de géraldine woessner voilà
pour le programme tout de suite place
aux grands débats
[Musique]
bonsoir fils et bâle ont souffert si
d'être avec nous vous êtes un grand
témoin ce soir vous avez évidemment
écouter le chef de l'état voudrait nous
dire dans un instant ce que vous en avez
pensé journalistes évidemment aussi un
directeur de la rédaction de charlie
hebdo qui fait je le disais c'est 50 ans
cette semaine on en parlera tout à
l'heure on parlera aussi un petit peu de
ce roman allegro barbaro avec ce
personnage d'ailleurs de rockstar et de
journalistes qui se rencontrent
notamment sur la route de sarajevo n'en
dira un mot tout à l'heure bonsoir et
khouya merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
député la république en marche de
gironde et vous est le co auteur d'un
rapport parlementaire sur la
radicalisation dans les services publics
avec vous eric diard c'est vous l'autre
auteur de ce rapport vous en avez fait
même un livre co écrit avec le
journaliste henri vernet radicalisation
au coeur des services publics sport
hôpitaux transports ce qu'on ne vous dit
pas c'est aux éditions jean claude
lattès va nous rejoindre dans un instant
le député stéphane peu député communiste
de seine saint denis et bonsoir stéphane
bonsoir muriaux makowsky qui
m'accompagne comme tous les soirs il
commence mieux le poste avec son billet
d'actu si j'ai bien compris c'est parti
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris ce soir si j'ai
bien compris myriam le président macro
nous a refait le coup du ni ni ni ni ce
pari souvenais pas le mini cd d'un
slogan forgé par mitterrand 88 pour
définir sa politique économique vers ni
privatisation ni nationalisation donc
c'est l'idée d'incarner une politique du
juste milieu ni privatisation pas trop à
droite ni nationalisation pas trop à
gauche donc le slogan de mâcon source
discours ça serait plutôt lui ni naïveté
ni stigmatisation donc pas naïfs paix
parce que c'est un peu le défaut de la
gauche est bien sûr pas de
stigmatisation parce que ça serait
plutôt le défaut de la droite ni gauche
ni droite de transcender les clivages ça
s'est très mal revient ce qu'il est
parvenu selon vous alors vous allez me
tapant débattre ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il a quand même essayer donc d'un
côté pas de naïveté donc souvent le
reproche qu'on lui fait à droite sais
pas si c'est le cas des rivières mais
c'est de ne pas savoir nommer les choses
donc là pour le coup il a nommé
précisément ce qui par les airs de
séparatisme islamistes il avait déjà
employé ce mot navajo au début de
l'année
et puis il a désigné précisément les
endroits vous savez y avait des menaces
dans les écoles dans les mosquées dans
les associations puis il a été même plus
loin il a donné une définition de ce
terme séparatisme islamistes et il en
fait un ennemi de la république ce à
quoi nous devons nous attaquer c'est le
séparatisme islamistes
c'est un projet conscient théorisé
politico religieux qui se concrétise par
des écarts répétés avec les valeurs de
la république qui se traduit souvent
dans la constitution d'une contre
société voilà la constitution d'une
contre société là faut pas dire qu'il
cède à la naïveté
concernant le ni stigmatisation qu at il
dit alors bien sûr ce point il ya bien
sûr les formules usages qu'on a entendu
pendant temps depuis longtemps sur ses
disques aux dons qu'il a dit pas d'
amalgame ça il réussit à le placer bien
sûr de les musulmans devaient pas se
sentir visés dans leur ensemble et quand
même un élément qui est plus propre et à
menzel macron c'est quand il dit que
dans le double pente ce séparatisme
la france notre pays à sa part donc
c'est quelque chose qu'il avait déjà dit
auparavant
soulignant le fait qu'ils avaient un
terreau en france que la france avait
une part de responsabilité
la bis après les attentats du bataclan
vie en 2015 donc il ya encore ministre
il est revenu un peu sur ce thème cette
fois son expression c'est à dire nous
avons construit notre séparatisme en
france
tulle a permis de pointer le fait qu' il
y avait des ghettos la république
m'assure est pessimiste en service
public
et puis le point que la discrimination
aussi c'était un discours équilibré
selon vous ni naïf ni stigmatisant toi
vous êtes là pour débattre mais moi je
serais tenté de penser que c'est surtout
il avoue tout faire nous montrer qu'il
avait surtout s'était écarté de toute
forme de naïveté en fait il ya un ce
n'est qu'un indice mais il ya la terre
qui l'a un peu épuisant fois dans le
discours ses insécurités culturel donc
c'est un sens à ses côtés qui a été
inventé par un géographe qui s'appelle
christophe du midi surtout le titre d'un
livre dans la sécurité culturelle de
laurent bouvet quelqu'un qui vient du ps
donc de la gauche mais qui s'est engagé
pour une radio de laïcité de combat en
disant que c'est très important de bien
identifier l'ennemi et de combattre
l'islamisme il est lié au printemps de
public un donc une certaine manière pour
assumer c'est un peu quelqu'un qui soit
prison de manuel valls
si bien que à la fin de la conférence et
de journée ce qui le dit mais manuel
valls a l'impression que vous êtes en
train de reprendre toutes ces idées ce
que vous
finalement vous faites comme manuel
valls 3 ans après on écoute la réponse
il faut pas tout
pour essayer de renvoyer les gens à des
caricatures de même ou au flipper des
commentaires je trouve qu'on est on est
constamment en train de faire ça il n'a
pas trop invite pas d'en parler mais la
question était bonne et ce qu'il fait
exactement ce que manuel valls 3 n'est
qu'à trois ans qu'il a presque trois ans
de retard on peut se demander ma
question je me pose c'est puisqu'il est
d'accord sur tout avec manuel valls
pourquoi valls n'est pas au gouvernement
sympa va l'attention merci c'était pas
du tout eric riyahi là il a bougé il a
changé sur ces sujets là c'est vrai
qu'on l'attendait presque depuis trois
ans ce discours vous reconnaissez qu'il
a évolué tout cas le candidat à
maquereau et le président maquereau ou
eclaron sur le discours a évolué et je
pense que c'est assez naturel dans la
mesure où il est en responsabilité il
s'est aujourd'hui face à la france et
face la situation de la france de 2020
et il ya des réalités certainement qui
lui en client pas qu'ils sont apparus et
face à c est celle ci il faut répondre
eric diard est sorti d'un big 8 et vous
en féliciter il est sorti au départ de
l'ambiguïté a été clair on parlait de
séparatisme de plusieurs séparatisme il
y en a nommé un le séparatisme islamique
on en parle et qui aurait peut-être des
histoires de suprématie sts blanche
pourquoi fait il n'était pas curiel les
séparatismes mais c'est une loi contre
le séparatisme vous en féliciter oui il
a été clair parce que c'était très long
quand même trois en trois ans de
tergiversations entre trois ans où on
annule on repart ensuite un moment il a
fait les premières annonces au mois de
février mais ensuite et la période de
kobe 19 qui a décalé ces annonces
donc il était temps avait quand même
joué à deux parties différentes une
première partie que qui était forte
notamment sur le la neutralité du
service public doit détailler dans
l'école et tetra et une deuxième partie
que j'ai trouvé un peu plus dans les
sports mais un peu plus philosophiques
et littéraires
stéphane peu bonsoir jean merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes député communiste je
le disais de seine-saint-denis ce matin
dans le parisien jean louis borloo
disait avant le discours il faut qu'ils
fassent nation qu'ils fassent république
le chef de l'état et le chef de la
nation on est un blanc qu'est-ce qu'il a
fait nation dans ce discours
oui et non je suis oui et non c'est à
dire qu'il ya toute une première partie
où il a une pose un diagnostic que je
trouve très juste sur les failles de
notre république et sur le risque de
séparatistes winum l'islam politique à
juste titre même si ce n'est pas la
seule menace sur ce rallye mais son
annulaire bien sûr aucun doute là dessus
mais ce n'est pas ce n'est pas là-dessus
qu'il englobe d'autres menaces oui bien
sûr il ya le le séparatisme social qui
moi m'a inquiète beaucoup quand
j'observe que pour la vingtième année
consécutive on s'aperçoit qu'en
ile-de-france à un véritable apartheid
urbain qui a trente secret entre les
quartiers pauvres et les quartiers
riches
c'est inquiétant parce qu'on ne fera
jamais république la république c'est un
bloc c'est un tout et donc c'est quand
même réunir autour et sur cette question
de l'islam politique
stéphane blakowski disait qu'il était
équilibré le communiste que vous êtes le
trouve si l'équilibré
non mes moyens je trouve que il fait un
très bon diagnostic et ils chutent sur
des propositions en hiver qui sont
relativement limités qu'on a c'est peu
d'envergure moi y en a certaines que je
veux que je partage mais je trouve que
c'est pas du tout à la hauteur des
enjeux
c'est un combat que vous menez depuis
des années et essayer de mettre des mots
sur les choses
la laïcité il parle d'android
endoctrinement de contre-société d'un
projet conscient théorisé politico
religieux qui se concrétise par des
écarts avec les lois de la république
avant d'entrer dans le détail vous
l'avez écouté quand elle vous pensez
écoutez là vraiment je dois dire que je
vais décider de brefs mais j'ai deux
périodes dans ma vie une période où j'ai
fais un métier de musicien d'artistes de
faim de seine quoi comme on dit et j'ai
joué partout donc je connais très bien
le tissu associatif français pendant
vingt ans j'ai sillonné la france et
j'ai vu le rôle des associations
j'ai vu comment ils se sont retirés
comment elles sont devenues autre chose
les ai vus muté etc
j'ai on a hélas après j'ai eu mon métier
de journaliste dans mon métier de
journaliste on a on a arrêté une petite
poignée mais vraiment très minoritaire à
me tirer la sonnette d'alarmé dès les
années 90 sur ces questions bref en et
disant pourvu que la république la
politique s'en saisissent parce que le
problème n'est pas tant sociale c'est
vrai qu'il y avait des quartiers pauvres
mais les immigrés qui peuplaient ces
quartiers pauvres avaient pour ambition
de s'en sortir mieux que la génération
précédente ce qui est normal dans pour
des immigrés enfin c'est la culture
normal des immigrés c'est le désir
normal des immigrés enfin celui qui est
le plus souhaitable et celui grâce
auquel ils s'en sortent mais il ya une
volonté politique de la part d'une
partie de cette immigration une partie
de cette immigration de ne pas s'en
sortir c'est à dire d'être contre la
république contre ce qu'un terminal
sisters 4/10 donc on voulait évidence
nation mitterrand sous les autres
présidents de la république chirac sarko
dur on a attendu un discours sur cette
question parce qu'on voyait on on a vu
tout ça change et ça lui du temps en
lumière fois qu'un président de la
république prend la parole en ces termes
sur cette question ça vingt ans de
retard c'est pas de la faute à mâcon ce
qu'il avait 20 ans quand il fallait en
parler
il en a donc on a pris énormément de
retard
la tâche va être d'autant plus difficile
mais au moins la république a parce
qu'on historiquement oui c'est un
discours très important je pense que
tous les pays d'europe vont s'intéresser
à ce discours parce que tous les pays
d'europe même si l'on pas les sociétés
organisées de la même façon que la nôtre
iso y connaît ce phénomène du dudu
radicalisation musulmane enfin la red
hat radicalisation sien dit au sein de
l'islam est une fois de plus la cause
n'est pas tant ce n'est pas si social
que ça même si le social les problèmes
sociaux sont un terreau n'ont reculé
mélanie des surnoms reculer nos lâche t
il à vous faire écouter le son mais on
n'aura pas le temps mais je vous le dis
ils ont méthodiquement construit leur
projet certes c'est aussi le oui mais
ils ont construit le même projet au
pakistan en algérie au liban dans des
pays qui au danemark dans des pays qui
n'ont rien à
ouart avait entre eux dont niveau social
donc ça montre bien que c'est un
problème politique
l'islam c'est de l'islam politique et le
ya un terreau social favorisant mais ça
existe
or du terreau social aurait dû ou pas
dire ce qu'il a dit sur nos recul sur la
faillite de la république est-ce que
c'est pas au fond il ya trois élus sur
ce plateau
vos responsabilités messieurs les élus
de droite comme de gauche c'est un
problème qui date de quoi de 30 ans moi
je suis est ce que est ce qu'il n'ya pas
une faillite des responsables politiques
moi je n'aime pas avoir fait en sorte
que ça n'arrive pas convaincu que la
république c'est c'est effectivement un
idéal auquel on adhère mais c'est aussi
une promesse ça quand on est en france
où quand on devient français ont fait le
choix d'être français ont la france la
république fait une promesse le dit
voilà maintenant vous allez être libres
égaux en droit dans une société
fraternelle et laïque faire quand c'est
pas le cas qu'il ya des failles quand il
ya un manque d'égards et non quand il y
en a et b c'est l'association c'est la
classe politique mais c'est aussi la
classe intellectuelle actuellement la
classe des clercs les enseignants
d'université les formateurs de profs les
formateurs de journalistes on a laissé
faire
là tous d'accord là-dessus bateau qu'on
fasse notre mea culpa
moi pas tout à fait parce que je veux
expliquer pourquoi les choses ont évolué
mais y arriver il joue pas de deux
éléments sous chirac il ya eu la loi sur
le voile à l'école sous sarkozy
il ya eu la loi sur le voile intégral ça
a provoqué beaucoup de polémiques
aujourd'hui la situation calme s'est
aggravée et je pense quand même que le
président pose le débat qui peut à mon
avis aujourd'hui être plus apaisée par
contre ça je la gauche a une
responsabilité oui voilà forcément même
est ce que disait philippe baile tout à
l'heure sur les émigrés d'avant et
d'aujourd'hui mais moi qui y vivent y
travaillent et suis élue à saint denis
depuis
depuis très longtemps l'immense majorité
de la population de cette ville qui est
pour une grande part issue de
l'immigration c'est toujours son
espérance et son espérance elle est dans
la république
quand vous êtes un ouvrier ou un
précaire et que vous avez un enfant
votre seule espérance pour le voir un
jour avoir un statut meilleur que le
vote c'est l'école de la république et
c'est intéressant pardonnez moi de vous
interromps mais vous parlez de l'école
il ya eu des écoles clandestines en
seine saint denis dont votre département
c'est sans doute l'annoncé la plus forte
l'instruction sera rendue obligatoire
dès 3 heures de la rentrée dès la
rentrée prochaine on écoute le chef de
l'état des parents d'élèves qui viennent
voir directeur ou la directrice d'école
et qui disent le cours de musique c'est
terminé sinon il ne reviendra plus la
piscine avec les autres c'est terminé
sinon il ne reviendra plus il ya ensuite
des certificats pour allergie au chlore
qui sont de mai puis des absences
répétées et enfin la déscolarisation
nous allons l'inscrire au cned ce sera
très bien fait c'est plus simple pour
nous ces enfants ne vont pas au cned
parfois ils ne reçoivent aucune
éducation mais ils vont dans des
structures qu'ils sont nullement déclaré
la semaine dernière nous en avons encore
identifié une en seine saint denis des
structures très simple des murs presque
pas de fenêtre des enfants qui arrivent
à 8 heures chaque jour qui repartent à
15h des femmes en niqab qui les
accueillent et lorsqu'on les interroge
des prières certains cours voilà le
renseignement c'est une réalité
nous devons à regarder la nommer en face
stéphane peut vous redonne la parole
cette école aux sept saints menées
clandestines bien décrite par le chef
d'état elle a été fermée vous lui dites
merci c'est ça veut dire qu'il y en aura
plus désormais il faudra poule mais des
trois ans et je dis pas merci quand les
lois de la république s'appliquent et
c'est laisser la loi de la république
qui qui s'applique et moi ce que je veux
dire parce que je les colle pour moi
c'est vraiment la base de tous notamment
pour construire une république qui fasse
bloc n'ont pas de mesure ou pas mais
bien sûr que c'est une bonne mesure les
obligations à trois ans mais est ce
qu'on peut mettre à côté de cette
affirmation
une autre réalité qui a été évité par le
président de la république sait que dans
un département comme la seine saint
denis où il ya une immense attente
vis-à-vis de l'école républicaine un
enfant entre la maternelle et la
primaire un enfant de la seine saint
denis
scolarisé à l'école publique est là
l'équivalent d'une année scolaire sans
professeur oui mais oui mais on peut pas
dire oui non les professeurs vont être
revalorisées mais j'aime vraiment et le
département ont plus besoin d'écoles
républicaine c'est là où la république
tient le monde réalisé écoles
clandestines mer en burqa fillette de 4
ans voit les lieux insalubres ouvrages
religieux interdit en france
eric diard la wii mais c'est la
contrepartie ma parole je vous donne un
exemple je suis fin j'étais favorable
ouaga tel sénatrice qui a renforcé le
contrôle dans les écoles hors contrat
mais ce renforcement dans les écoles
hors contrat a contrario c'est la
contrepartie a entraîné le développement
des écoles clandestines
donc j'y suis favorable mais on s'est
très plus de contrôle sur leur contrat
mais il va falloir surveiller parce
qu'ils risquent comme tout est surveillé
i rode da clandestinité qui risque de se
développer les balles sur l'école et
puis on avance et je vous donne ma
parole je veux dire que cette
contestation de l'école de l'école de la
république
elle n'est pas social elle est politique
une fois de plus s'il s'agit bien et
j'ai insisté là dessus d'un islam
politique seul ennemi c'est l'islam
politique
ça n'est pas une revendication sociale
on veut plus de profs c'est un problème
énorme mais peut-être qu'on pourrait en
parler cette histoire de deux profs
manquant sur tant d'années ça fait un an
pratiquement de perdus pour un enfant il
est difficile de la république mais
c'est aussi difficile de nommer des
profs en seine saint denis tout le monde
court pas pour aller enseigner là bas
et voilà il faut se poser la question
pourquoi mais tout le monde connaît la
réponse en réalité à l'argent parce que
c'est pas sûr c'est pas un c'est pas une
guerrière face il faudrait qu'on avance
parce qu'elle beaucoup de choses et je
vous donne la parole sur le renforcement
de la neutralité dans les services
publics c'est l'objet de votre livre
eric diard en particulier il ya ces
questions de chauffeurs de bus il ya ces
questions aussi de deux menus
confessionnels écouter le chef de l'état
d'autres élus exclus au projet d'exclure
les hommes les femmes de certains
créneaux d'accès aux piscines
ce fut par exemple le cas dans une
commune non loin d'ici ou des femmes ont
revendiqué des horaires d'accès distinct
des hommes à la piscine une fois la loi
votée le préfet pourra suspendre les
actes municipaux correspondant à ces
situations en constatant cette carence
républicaine et si sa décision n'était
pas appliquée se substituer à l'autorité
locale avec l'accord du là encore c'est
les élus qui vont être mis sous pression
le préfet s'est substitué si par exemple
les menus confessionnels les horaires de
piscine sont aménagés ça veut dire aussi
que les élus d'une certaine façon c'est
un peu raté du droit de regard sur une
mesure comme celle ci par la première
c'est ce que vous décrivez c'est à dire
qu'un élu qui pourrait transiger un
petit peu ou qui pourrait effectivement
avoir une vision un petit peu lâche de
la république dans son département
inscription le préfet pourra
effectivement compte revenir à sa
décision mais vous avez un deuxième une
deuxième dimension ce que vous entendez
dans votre remarque c'est que la
pression sociale et la pression on va
dire du territoire et peut être très
forte et le jules-courmont parfois du
mal à refuser représente peu faut
prononcer le vrai père le mot voilà ils
ont peur et donc une décision de l'état
par le via le préfet pourra aussi
pacifier le chèque d'arrhes sur les
services publics
vous qui avez travaillé sur le sportif
avec qui restent vives en basque est
annoncé on peut penser pas si vous savez
c'est pas le programme c'est pas le pôle
la proposition de loi c'est une esquisse
donc on peut je peux pas vous dire c'est
suffirent pas suivi d'un il ya des
choses intéressantes notamment quelque
chose qu'on avait bien noté à travers le
rapport
notamment les le transport qui
concernait mais il ya les délégations de
service public qui échappe à la
neutralité du service public
voilà c'est pour sa session c'est ce que
je dis si simple je vous donne un
exemple
alors il vous avez la ratp qui respecte
qui essaie de respecter la neutralité du
service public
et vous avez qui ne fait pas rentrer une
femme
son but qu'est ce qu'on fait il est
sanctionné administrativement de
sept-îles mais par contre être différent
je vous dis entre un service public
comme la ratp est une entreprise qui
fait office de service public qui pour
l'instant a délégation est donc cet
alignement de l'apa et président de la
république est plutôt intéressant il va
dans le bon sens c'est très important
non c'est très important ce que je le
j'ai bien lu et le rapport de mes
collègues et grosso modo je veux pas
trahir mais grosso modo le service
public avec ses principes tient à peu
près correctement il ya quelques
endroits où ces mêmes enfin globalement
tient bien sûr les questions de la
laïcité de la neutralité est par contre
les grosses failles sont dans les
délégations de service public où ne
s'appliquent pas les mêmes les mêmes
entreprises précisément ça peut être du
nettoyage ça
vous avez des équipements sportifs ou
culturels qui sont à même de les léguer
la marge est peut être plus intéressant
vous mentionniez tout à leurs rivales la
question des associations il y aura
désormais une charte de principes
républicains que toutes les associations
devront signer et respecter alors
comment ça va se passer
thomas des prêts et olivier molinari se
sont rendus à nice nice ville
laboratoire
reportage je vous remets le bulletin
d'adhésion n'a c'est devenu un rituel
avant chaque rentrée associative
chaque fois que nous produisons un
dossier à la ville de nice il faut
également signé cette charte
comme jean fournier qui préside l'une
des plus vieilles associations
culturelles de la ville depuis 2016 tous
les directeurs d'associations doivent
s'engager à respecter les valeurs de la
république
ça permet à chacun de recadrer un petit
peu le look et le cadre de la des
pratiques sportives des pratiques
culturelles savoir ça c'est pas
n'importe comment
et c'est surtout c'est surtout pas un
motif pour faire autre chose une
initiative portée par le maire les
républicains de la ville christian
estrosi
nous avons des principes de nous
exigeons notamment l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes
le principe de neutralité des bâtiments
la liberté de conscience et la liberté
de culte et l'égalité de tous devant la
loi quelle que soit leur croyance ou
leurs convictions
quatre pages d'engagement et en cas de
non respect d'un des principes
la ville a tout prévu c'est simple une
association me demande une subvention et
plus de subventions une association me
demande un terrain de foot un équipement
sportif un gymnase une salle pour tenir
des conférences
il ya plus d'équipements donc
l'association n'a plus les moyens de
mener son activité c'est après une
polémique que christian estrosi a eu
l'idée de cette charte il y a cinq ans
sur ce terrain de sport à l'ouest de la
ville
un incident avait beaucoup fait réagir
en plein match de foot des joueurs avant
un match
en chercher le lieu le plus approprié
sur le terrain pour faire des prières un
acte inacceptable pour ig borghini alors
patron du district côte d'azur il a à
l'époque soutenu la charte de la mairie
ça a eu un effet tout à fait efficace
parce qu'on a eu deux trois cas au début
en 2016 et ensuite on n'a pratiquement
plus aucune
aucun incident un peu plus loin même
constat au pied des tours de la cité des
moulins
pour le président du club la religion
n'a pas sa place sur le gazon l'entente
couvre on leur propose ce soit pour les
musulmans la mosquée ou pour des
chrétiens l'église et qu'ils sont libres
de d'avoir n'importe quelle religion on
appartenir laquelle n'importe quelle
religion qui aura pas d'à priori sur la
religion en tout cas au niveau de la
pratique sportive et que l'on reste dans
cette obscure en leur expliquant qu' à
des lieux cultes justement pour pour
pratiquer que sur un terrain de foot on
a pas on n'a pas cette image à avoir
d'un jeune qui doit faire sa prière sur
un terrain de foot du côté des joueurs
même si aucun incident n'a été observée
depuis sa mise en place
cette charte interroge toujours le mec
fait sa prière dans un coma dont un truc
moi je suis pas contre un joueur qui va
rentrer sur le terrain faire le signe de
croix où un joueur qui va qui va rentrer
car cette prière ou bien qui va faire sa
prière à l'heure dans les vestiaires
personnellement moi ça me gêne pas si
demain c'est des juifs du chrétien est
ce que peut-être ça poserait aucun
problème
on sait pas sur cette dernière remarque
elle vous sur quoi ont passé les balles
oui ça poserait aujourd'hui évidemment
autant de problème il n'y a aucun doute
là-dessus et met une fois de plus avant
que l'islam politique ne viennent
envahir un certain espace social ces
discussions là n'avaient jamais lieu le
groupe dans les années 70-80 je vous
soutiens vraiment rappeler ça en dehors
des associations sportives dès 1901 sur
le sport les associations culturelles
était il y avait un maillage énorme en
france
à tel point qu'il ya eu des enquêtes
menées là-dessus 90% des manifestations
culturelles théâtre cinéma musique en
france était en bout de chaîne produite
par des associations 1901
maintenant c'est beaucoup privatisée et
surtout il ya eu beaucoup de retrait
de gens parce que c'était des
associations population très diverse
vous les avez connus et on a vu partir
beaucoup de gens issus de l'immigration
qui était dense et dans ces milieux là
donc ce genre de discussions n'avaient
jamais lieu n'aurait été inimaginable on
voit que c'est assez efficace anus vous
allez pouvoir au fond réguler les
subventions publiques stéphane que si
ces personnes dans les associations ne
respectent pas les principes de la
république
eh bien vous couper les subventions
c'est une aide oui oui oui c'est une
aide
un jour je regardais la charte denise
moi j'étais maire adjoint à saint denis
j'ai fait signer une charte de la
laïcité en 2002 aux associations qui
faisait du soutien scolaire donc on
s'est quand même pas une invention très
récente
après tout le problème et le contrôle de
tout ça parce que franchement cabine
l'association qui fait du soutien
scolaire dans un club sportif c'est
encore enfin on va pas en personne ne
passe toutes les semaines ou plusieurs
fois par semaine voir ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur du court donc il faut faire
attention à ne pas non plus se faire
plaisir à bon compte
il faut des choses qui soient efficaces
mais c'est important de réunir ce que je
faisais à s'amener ont réuni c'est tout
le monde dans une salle en expliciter
cette charte de la laïcité en expliquer
les principes et chacun solennellement
chaque président d'association venait la
signer bon c'est savait surtout un
mérite pédagogique
oui merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
président du cfcm
on a entendu beaucoup le nom de votre
institution dans la bouche du président
de la république tout à l'heure le cfcm
c'est le conseil français du culte
musulman on va parler à présent des
mesures qui concerne le culte les
mosquées et les imams le financement de
ces mosquées
peut-être la première annonce peut-être
la plus importante
il n'y aura désormais plus c'est pas
tout de suite mais progressivement plus
d'imams étrangers en france
écoute emmanuel macron vous réagissez
juste avant vous le savez nous sommes un
pays où nous organisions la formation
des imams dans des pays étrangers
aussi celle de psalmodie heures que nous
faisions venir de manière régulière
c'est la turquie le maroc et l'algérie
qui fournissait ses imams et cepsa
demandeurs nous avons décidé de mettre
fin à ce système de manière totalement
apaisé avec les pays d'origine et en
transition c'est-à-dire sur quatre ans
en moyenne ce qu'il faut que les choses
se fassent progressivement parce que je
vais revenir nous allons nous-mêmes
former nos imams et de psalmodie les
musulmans en france
mohammed moussaoui c'est la fin
programmée des imams étrangers vous
saluer cette mesure oui je pense a été
déjà prises en 2019
pendant son discours de mulhouse que là
c'est officiel la fin de l'islam
consulaires ça veut dire la fin des
imams étrangers en france les musulmans
de france eux-mêmes et sont conscients
qu'il faut former des imams français des
jeunes français qui ont vécu dans un
contexte français parce qu'un imam venus
d'ailleurs ne peut pas comprendre les
préoccupations des jeunes et d'une
d'être à leur écoute et puis surtout de
les prémunir face aux risques qu'ils ont
cours dans une société comme la nôtre on
a plus de problème en france avec les
mêmes étrangers ont pas franchement vous
qui connaissez pas forcément avec lise
et un étranger je pense le leur handicap
c'était la langue et un manque de
connaissance du contexte cultura sinon
il n'y a jamais eu d'imams détachées qui
était objet de poursuites ou ou d'un
délit quelconque alors c'est vous qui
allez devoir au fond vous atteler à ce
gros dossier puisque 1905 oblige c'est
pas l'état qui va faire ça c'est vous
vous allez devoir former les imams vous
avez 4 euros pour le faire mais dans six
mois si j'ai bien écouté le président
vous allez devoir travailler à des
certifications d'imams des
labellisations de formation et écrire
une charte dont le non-respect
entraînera tout simplement la révocation
d'imams est prêt je joue comme vous le
savez le conseil français du culte
musulman dès sa fondation il a été conçu
pour être une structure légère qui n'a
pas de responsabilité cultuelle c'est
important de le dire aujourd'hui donc
manque de moyens
et automatiquement et je pense que ça
serait ça dépendra énormément de la
volonté de composantes du conseil
français du culte musulman
six mois c'est peu mais je pense que le
défi qui est devant nous va nous inciter
tous à mettre les bouchées on va dire
les les bouchées doubles et et de
pouvoir laisser tout ce qui pourrait
freiner cette cette réalisation va on en
a des imams en france
ce qu'il faut les former parce que tout
ça c'est c'est souhaitable est ce que
c'est possible tout ce qu'il faut dire
en tout cas des immeubles qui ont
parfois prôné une société qui n'est pas
feinte qui n'est pas la nôtre qui en
parfois défendu un modèle je dirais
politique contrôle public y en a et on
l'est certainement on les a chassés de
notre territoire pression voilà combien
vous savez à premier exactement je ne
sais pas mais mais ça montre que la
faille est là donc je pense qu'il est
important mais moi je voudrais juste
dire parce que c'est quand même pas trop
mal dire c'est que il faut absolument et
je pense que ça a été le sel c'est en
filigrane dans la dans l'expression du
président c'est que on a pas à dire à
une femme comment il doit s'organiser ou
comment il doit voilà tout ce qu'ils ont
sur la structuration et mais tout ce
système en tant que représentant par
rapport à l'état une des tentatives
finalement sont cassés les dents enfin
je veux dire voilà je pense qu'il faut
par contre en revanche est allé il faut
prendre à l'origine à la source de la
chose effectivement je veux dire l'islam
respecte beaucoup
l'imam et il a une place prépondérante
dans dans l'art dans la représentation
symbolique et c'est là qu'il faut
prendre la source du problème et j'ai
une petite question
dès lors on entendait
philivan nous parler du problème de
l'islam politique en disant c'est un
problème politique
ce n'est qu'un problème il ya une ménade
mâcon qui a dit il ya une crise de
l'islam dans le monde
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça je
pense l'une des mairies de ce discours
c'est qu'il était clair par rapport à
l'objet de la proposition de loi est
donc de viser un extrémisme qui de
l'islam qui est ce que l'islam traverse
une crise ya un extrémisme qui dévoila
religion musulmane partout dans le monde
et il menace les musulmans eux mêmes
si on regarde bien si les musulmans de
france où les musulmans du monde d'une
manière générale sont les victimes de
ceux de cet extrémisme qui dévoila
religion musulmane c'est dans ce sens le
combat que mène le président a public et
que même la république c'est aussi le
combat des musulmans de france
je combats de l'islam des lumières que
vous allez tout pense que l'immense
majorité des musulmans de france aspire
à vivre leur spiritualité dans la paix
le respect et c'est vrai que
l'extrémisme se réclamant de l'islam a
peut-être des femmes politiques à des
fins en tout cas contraire aux valeurs
de la république
ceux là sont nos ennemis sur nos ennemis
communs il faut les combattre ensemble
on a un moment important carrefour et
super société l'a offert ce
sous-ensemble il ya ces questions de
mosquée de de loi 1901 il vous a dit
d'ailleurs de faire arrêter la loi 1901
pour arrêter l'opacité passé en 1905
alors c'est un peu technique mais
comment comment on peut y arriver alors
je pense que là le l'oeil populaire si
méfiants sur la politique si méfiants
sur l'islam
si méfiants si presque hostile peut se
trouver là un objet de réconciliation
dans les mois qui viennent je pense que
le travail législatif qui va avoir lieu
maintenant s'il a lieu de façon efficace
et digne avec des oppositions parfois
normal mais pas combat de chiffonniers
de partie parce que c'est le bien commun
dont il est question c'est éviter la
guerre de tous contre tous finalement
c'est la légitimité de l'état et donc si
ce débat entre vous à la chambre a lieu
d'une façon ça va être regardé
énormément par les gens parce que c'est
un sujet qu'il aurait trait
cher et c'est l'occasion veut être où
jamais de marquer des points dans la
confiance que les gens peuvent faire
dans la politique
est-ce que c'est pas le moment d'une
union nationale sur un sujet qu'on s'est
extrêmement sensible éruptif mais ce qu
au fond une loi votée clairement
discuter amender
c'est possible moi je l'espère j'espère
que soient les fondamentaux de la
république on puisse se retrouver avec
bien sûr nos sensibilités et nos
expériences mais ce qui me préoccupe
c'est eux c'est que tous nos concitoyens
s'y retrouve et je suis très très
sensible à la façon et je le saurai ce
week-end en allant dans ma dans ma ville
de saint denis
je suis très intéressé je n'ai pas eu le
temps de le faire depuis ce matin de
voir comment tous mes compatriotes de
confession musulmane qui sont nombreux à
s'amener vivent ce moment là parce que
on réussira l'unité nationale dont vous
parlez pas seulement en réunissant les
politiques mais en faisant en sorte que
tous nos concitoyens à commencer par nos
concitoyens de confession musulmane se
retrouve dans dans dans et donc et donc
pas ce que vous pouvez pas ignorer
surtout en étant journaliste quand même
la musique médiatique que l'on entend
qui est enfin qui montre matin midi et
soir non pas les intégristes musulmans
mais les musulmans qui les montre du
doigt en permanence et donc il ya un
malaise dans la communauté
vous allez écouter le président vous
avez trouvé que que ce discours n'était
pas stigmatisant et les équilibres et
vous l'accompagnerez je pense qu'ils
n'étaient pas stigmatiser en soi mais il
a clairement conscience que les débats
qui vont suivre peuvent l'être
et d'ailleurs je consulte des questions
qui ont été posées par un de vos
confrères
il disait clairement ça va être ça va
dépendre de vous ça va dépendre comment
va traiter ce problème et c'est vrai que
dans ce genre de débat tous les débats
qui ont précédé un certain nombre de
projets de loi
on a vécu des moments très difficiles et
musulmans de france le langage aille
avec les langages le langage lui-même y
est pas si vous entendez
die in cristallise on vous avez tout de
suite à l'esprit une religions et
civilisations des croyants lorsque vous
entendez vous entendez islamisme vous
devez penser à autre chose
c'est déjà un début de déséquilibrer de
rudes et d'amalgamés de confusion entre
islam islamisme avant les années
soixante dix effectivement islamisme
c'était l'équivalent de l'islam
malheureusement il ya un choix qui a été
fait pour désigner une
instrumentalisation à des fins
politiques la religion musulmane par un
terrain qui est qui et islam is he en
partie de la responsabilité va
maintenant peser sur vos épaules pour
justement faire ce travail de pédagogie
vous êtes prêt nous pendant tout moment
dans la saison donc de faire un travail
auprès de nos coreligionnaires s'achever
jour eh oui elle est non je suis juste
inquiets sur le calendrier
parce que le président a parlé
aujourd'hui la loi arrive au conseil des
ministres en décembre
elle va faire son parcours parlementaire
pour aboutir en fin de parcours
parlementaire six mois avant l'élection
présidentielle
franchement si elle n'est pas retoquée
basket n'est pas retoquée mec c'est trop
relais il ne sait pas que c'est trop
rapide c'est que vous savez ce que c'est
qu'une campagne présidentielle en france
elle cristallise beaucoup de débats
beaucoup de tension je ne suis pas sûr
que ce soit le bon timing pour faire
l'unité nationale merci beaucoup je
voudrais qu'on s'arrête un instant sur
vous philippe val c'est intéressant ce
livre on va dire un mot mais il ya un
contexte dont je voudrais qu'on parle
tout de suite ce drôle d'anniversaire
que fait charlie
[Musique]
comptant 50 ans au compteur pour
l'hebdomadaire satirique
alors évidemment si les balles il ya une
longévité qui fait très plaisir 50 ans
c'est beaucoup pour l'histoire d'un
journal avec une parenthèse à
l'intérieur de ses 50 ans de 11 ans sont
publication c'est vrai mais il ya en
même temps un contexte historiquement ça
a commencé il ya 50 ans il ya eu dix ans
avant que cabu moines on refonde le
journal
il a il avait cessé de paraître pendant
dix ans mais il ya un contexte dans
lequel et fêter cet anniversaire
qu'est ce que vous vous ressentez en ce
moment dans cette période post attentats
dans cette période de procès je pense
que le journal qu'on a remis en route
cabu et moi 92 à fait dignement son
travail je pense que le mercredi la
publication la présence de charlie dans
les kiosques même pour ceux qui n'aiment
pas ce journal ce que je peux
parfaitement comprendre
il ya des jours donc j'aime pas beaucoup
de si bons donc on a le droit de cette
question de goût mais le fait que
charlie soit le mercredi dans les
kiosques indiqué à tout le monde qu'on
était dans une démocratie parce que
c'est un journal transgressive parce que
c'est un journal avec une grande liberté
voilà c'était un signal et je pense que
ce signal
ce ce message de charlie a servi à
quelque chose
je pense qu'avec l'actuelle direction a
extrêmement courageuse charlie symbolise
quelque chose de même une fois de plus
pour les gens qui n'aiment pas le
contenu éditorial du journal je pense
que charlie hebdo est précieux
aujourd'hui parce que il est le signe
d'une vraie démocratie quand vous voyez
au tout début du procès richard malka
l'avocat de charlie avait ses mots
extrêmement durs et noir en dix ans les
terroristes ont gagné la peur a gagné
l'autocensure a gagné vous vous êtes
d'accord
ah oui je partage complètement le pignon
de richard on s'est battu pendant
longtemps pour ça on a vu le legends
avoir peur de dessiner dans le manifeste
oui tout la même
et c'est des années et des années de
travail avant d'arriver à ce résultat
comme le discours du président macron
aujourd'hui c'est des années d' alerte
des années d' alerte on nous disait
taisez vous et où les autres journaux
dans leur majorité pas tous mais dans la
majorité se taisaient refuser ou le
monde intellectuel ne voulait pas voir
la réalité du problème donc charlier a
été courageux riz c'est un formidable
directeur de ce journal est il ay là il
donne du sens à ces quelques avancées
pour nous quand même le jeu quand le
président m'a kron a dit il ya quelques
jours déjà le blasphème c'est un droit
inaliénable nous ces quinze années de
travail pour qu'un président de la
république
enfin 10 cette chose là vous vous
souriez vous vous êtes d'accord
lesquels nous acceptons bien sûr la loi
au-delà de jeu mais je juge toujours dit
en fait le droit de l'expression entre
dans l'expression et la liberté de
france et il ya la fraternité et je
dirais que rien absolument rien ne
justifie la violence
merci on va dire un mot de cabu votre
ami cabut philippe val
robin à l'émission de patrick cohen avec
l'ina sur lcp le consacre une émission
spéciale ce dimanche extrait merci
messieurs c'est valable avec le le
nouveau président la pub et est valable
avec l'ancien 6 4 2 oui ça marche
toujours avant fait voir tu vas voir
alors là un grand si ce joli cap alors
blessé un gardien alors le 2 faut le
faire un petit peu comme ça vous étiez
un peu de fantaisie un petit peu que
tout le toit
je vois très bien ah et puis tu
continues jusqu'à 2 voilà ah bravo voilà
pour les 6 4 voilà je gémis le talent de
cabu on a reconnu dorothée c'est s&p
récré a2 à l'époque vous vous participé
d'ailleurs à l'émission un sur le
plateau de rembobiner avec avec patrick
cohen qu'est ce qu'ils représentaient
pour vous avez cette anecdote à nous
raconter sur cabut enfin je canton
serait un canton se baladait avec cabu
dans des villes ou dans des pays d'abord
c'est un journaliste absolument
incroyable il remarque est toujours le
truc signifiant bon bref mais en plus
les gens partout le reconnaissait des
ils ont tous les gosses l'avait vu à la
télévision quand il devenait adulte se
rester une espèce d'idole de leur
enfance il faisait vraiment partie de
l'imaginaire des français
c'est le seul qui décide et tout paraît
qu'ils ont eux mêmes décidé dans sa
poche sans même regarder ce qui dans sa
poche il avait eu des fois il avait un
petit bout de crayon rang comme ça et
avec des petits bouts de papier et il
prenait des notes comme ça après il
faisait des dessins mais mais il voyait
quelque chose
un portail un portrait à lettrage sur un
camion fans il prenait des notes de
dessin tout le temps tout le temps tout
le temps tout on dit un petit modèle les
gros barbaro même s'il nous reste plus
beaucoup de temps
il ya un narrateur alors qu'il s'appelle
et miki marleau qui vous ressemble pas
mal c'est un journaliste un peu
mélancolique qui écrit la journée chante
le soir fait de la musique ça me
rappelle votre ancienne vie de
chansonniers et il rencontre une
rockstar en pleine guerre de yougoslavie
et ça ça donne envie
ouais ils s'en vont essayer de faire des
concerts de réconciliation dans un pays
en guerre ce qui est un peu aberrant et
un peu dingue
et voilà c'est indigne à une intrigue
avec ces groupes de rock qui parlera au
coeur des ténèbres au fond c'est un peu
vous se taire le narrateur et il a des
points communs avec moi oui les romans
la meilleure forme
non j'en écrirai un autre derrière mais
non je veux continuer à faire des essais
et des deux des romans aussi je pense
une bande d'utopistes rock'n'roll sur la
route de sarajevo allegro barbaro c'est
donc aux édition de l'observatoire tout
de suite le bloc-notes géraldine
woessner du point qui fait son grand
retour
ravi de vous conduire père vous êtes
passé déjà dans cette émission depuis sa
reprise pour la campagne américaine et
de presse donald trump ultra très
évidente
on est sous le choc et camille saféris
pour son apéro du vendredi soir avec un
député on va commencer avec géraldine
géraldine vous voulez pousser un coup de
gueule sur sur le bien-être animal alors
et on sait qu'une proposition de loi
eds écologie démocratie solidarité qui
prévoit l'interdiction de l'élevage en
cage d'ici 20 ans c'est trop long
intense est trop court c'est quoi le
problème mais tout dépend myriam ce
débat il est passionnant parce qu'ils
interrogent notre définition de la
souffrance est ce qu'on parle de
douleurs physiques ou d'autres choses
écoutez ce qu'en dit cédric villani le
cochon dans ces bâtiments n'est pas dans
des conditions où il peut satisfaire ses
besoins physiologiques les plus
fondamentaux en particulier ceux de
fuissé ce grenier se bouger et on les a
mis là dans un des coins sont insolubles
nos éleveurs avec ce mouvement
d'industrialisation le critère numéro un
c'était la production voilà j'ai choisi
cet extrait parce que il dit beaucoup
on voit cette vision idéalisée de
l'élevage préindustrielle en gros pour
monsieur villani il ya eu un avant-goût
les ports étaient heureux dans la cour
de ferme
c'est un mythe je vous épargne la
plongée dans les descriptions des sous à
cochons des villes du xviie siècle un
cauchemar de maladie de souffrances on
perd c'est à l'époque le groupe
des gorets avec des fils de fer on
incise est leur tendons pour les
empêcher de fuir de ravager avant ce
livre 1835 décrit par le menu l'art
d'extirper les ovaires détruits au
couteau pour qu'elles s'engraissent
mieux bref l'homme est un loup pour le
cochon et ça n'est pas nouveau rien à
voir avec l'industrialisation ce qu'il
est en revanche et c'est tant mieux
c'est le regard que nous nous portons
sur ces espèces qu'on a créé pour les
consommer c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs la
législation a évolué à contre-courant en
général on ne sait pas génial ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui on les castre quand
même bien sûr s'en émouvoir vous
l'accordé oui je vous la corde c'est
vrai on les castre y compris dans les
élevages bio d'ailleurs et vous savez
pourquoi on les castre parce qu'une
viande non castré dans de très rares cas
1 2% dégage une odeur puissante et ça
les consommateurs n'en veulent pas on
les laisse pas sortir non plus les
cochons pour des raisons économiques et
en réguler mieux en bâtiment les
températures l'alimentation des bagarres
0,9 pour cent seulement des ports où on
mange en france on taxait à l'extérieur
et je parle pas je parle d'une courette
1 c'est vraiment un petit accès alors
est-ce que ça peut changer en 20 ans
admettons qu'on puisse changer tous les
bâtiments le coût a été évalué ces 13
milliards d'euros mais sur énorme mais
est ce que les gens vont payer parce que
les mêmes français qui signent des
pétitions pour l'interdiction des cages
mais il refuse de payer même même 5%
d'augmentation pour leurs jambes ont le
label rouge pour les porcs ces quatre et
demi pour cent de la production est bien
plus de la moitié est déclassée en
sortie d'abattoirs parce qu'il n'y a pas
de client pour l'acheter donc on le vend
comme du cochon normale dont finalement
ce débat il est intéressant parce qu'il
nous place en face à nos contradictions
et à nos responsabilités
c'est facile de signer une pétition
beaucoup moins d'ouvrir son portefeuille
si on demain on apporte en masse du
cochon de batterie on n'aura rien fait
pour la cause animale
on aurait simplement tuer nos éleveurs
une telle réaction là dessus le
bien-être animal c'est devenu une cause
politique
mais c'est parfois un peu facile de
dénoncer les choses l'élevage industriel
c'est compliqué comme dossier oui mais
il ya une moi j'ai toujours
j'ai toujours pensé
une urgence la souffrance animale est un
problème dans nos sociétés modernes
démocratique c'était ça dit quelque
chose d'elle ça dit quelque chose de
leur de leurs imperfections de du refus
de la réalité
on doit de toute façon faire d'immenses
progrès dans la façon dont on traite les
animaux
j'ai toujours été un militant de la
cause animale et charlie hebdo a
toujours été un militant de la cause
animale journal qui militait contre la
souffrance animale c'est dans sa charte
d'ailleurs dans la charte de charlie
hebdo pour élaborer en 92
on passe à françois alors françois c'est
le choc pour quels rebondissements sur
donald trump a le coc vitesse qu'il
arrête sa compagne qu'est ce qui va se
passer
oui alors il arrête en tout cas ses
meetings c'est compliqué pour lui parce
que pendant dix jours il va être isolé à
la maison blanche
dix jours sur 32 ça fait qui perd un
tiers de sa campagne restantes c'est
vrai un 20 étapes problème puis ça
touche à son discours
c'était l'invulnérabilité de donald
trump
il ya trois ans différence avec thomas
hayden mais il nous faisait croire qu'il
était en super santé or là les
américains découvrent qu'il est déjà
allé à l'hôpital 16 novembre 2019 qui ce
qui s'y est passé
oui alors officiellement le pour
l'instant le médecin dit pour l'instant
ça va tout va bien et c'est mémé il a 74
ans mais il est encore morbidité 110 kg
ça passe sur tous les journaux
américains
c'est bien obésité et donc qu'est ce qui
va se passer et puis surtout c'est
l'arroseur arrosé il se moquait de joe
biden en disant même à 200 mètres il
porte un masque géant d'ailleurs vous
pouvez pas le voir sans qu'ils aient
c'était quoi son objectif c'était de
détourner l'attention des américains de
sa gestion du coc vide 19 or la loco vie
matin midi et soir
il y en a qui est dans une bulle en
plastique cemac ps parce qu'évidemment
vie on ne protège et on jamais
l'huile est négatif attention 25e
amendement ça veut dire que peut-être
évidemment s'il est empêché my pants
deviendrait président c'est déjà arrivé
à un georges de beaulieu bush en 2002 et
en 2007 c'était dick cheney qui l'a
remplacé pour des coloscopies et donc
voilà on va attendre mais c'est quand
même un rebondissement incroyable
vous voyez ça n'arrête pas je pense que
la rareté notre opinion oui notre
opinion mais l'amérique
quoi qu'on en pense et l'appui grandes
puissances démocratiques
c'est le plus grand état libre le plus
grand état de droit du monde de plus
puissant qui exerce un pouvoir à la fois
de modèles et de protection sur toutes
les démocraties du monde
or ce leadership américain elle s'est
effondrée avec trucks et il a laissé
l'europe et on ne mesure pas le danger
que l'on court dans le monde aujourd'hui
enfin je parle en face d'un
géopoliticien si que lorsque l'on a
perdu ce leadership américain on est un
con a perdu avec trump c'est une
histoire beaucoup plus violentes qu'on
le pense on sait pas comment ça peut
tourner les élections américaines
il a très mal tourné ça peut très mal
tourné parce que un refus des résultats
peut créer dans les rues d'une violence
qu'on inimaginable je dis pas j'espère
que ça n'arrivera pas mais effectivement
un seul mot qui qui qui en fait va tout
à fait dans votre sens
les sondages depuis depuis avant-hier on
sait depuis un an même depuis le débat
maintenant ses sept à huit points
d'avancé n'y a pas eu d'avancée aussi
importante depuis bob dole en 2000 en
donc ça veut dire qu'il a une avance
beaucoup plus grande qu hillary clinton
joe biden est le paradoxe est bien c'est
qu'il ya une majorité d'américains qui
disent on va voter pour joe biden mais
ils sont à 50 50 les deux parce que les
américains se disent est ce qui va pas
quand même gagné le collège électoral
est ce que les sondages se trompent ou
pas et troisième élément d'incertitude
est ce qu'il va voler l'élection alors
ça peut reporter déjà on va parler oui
c'est le 3 9 en mai là il ya un débat
télé alors ça peut reporter le débat
télé
ça va être juste 10 jours et sa défense
ont été en fait tout dépend on va voir
dans les 24 prochaines heures
on peut pas cacher la santé du président
est-ce qu'il est asymptomatique et ce
qui va bien est ce que comme boris
johnson il va être très gravement malade
l'amérique est suspendue parce que vous
avez donald trump il est capable de
retourner un peu les choses a toujours
il essaie quand même un fin politicien
et il est capable de dire j'ai surmonté
le copil clair je n'ai pas été voilà
donc il va essayer quand même d'utiliser
d'ailleurs même d'autres dirigeants qui
ont eu copie
je suis contre la loi vous connaissez
camille saféris une balle c'est un
charmant jeune homme comédiens sur les
planches mais aussi chroniqueur dans
notre émission et cinq vendredi soir
figurez-vous qu'il nous fait connaître
un député un peu autrement il eu des
temps autour d'un verre ça s'appelle la
période camille avec qui avez-vous
traquer cette semaine et bien myriam
pour commencer la saison j'ai choisi une
des grandes figures de l'assemblée c'est
tout le monde le connaît c'est pas
vraiment une découverte c'est charles de
courson a saisi les députés centristes
de la marne
ça fait presque 28 ans qui les députés
longue et c'est pas un c'est pas un
petit jeunot qui on l'appelle le moine
soldat cesson ce son surnom il est issu
d'une grande lignée la lignée des le
peletier de saint-fargeau
vous saviez pas à mâcon son grand père a
refusé les pleins pouvoirs à pétain un
de ses aïeux a voté pour l'exécution de
louis saez voyez le pedigree alors
charles de courson il est extrêmement
sympathique et mais il faut il faut le
dire il a eu deux suspensions de permis
pour des excès de vitesse non ci s'est
vu retiré pas moins à trois reprises en
dix ans alors il a dû faire des stages
de récupération de points bon intérêt
vous imaginez le truc quatre ou cinq ans
même
bon en fait il me l'a avoué il a tout
simplement une tendance à conduire trop
vite en début de journée je suis à
l'heure je commence à l'heure mais
souvent ça dérape et après j'essaie de
rattraper le temps quoi çà et là il vous
reste combien de points sur votre permis
en ce moment elle a dormi
neuf des policiers comment ils ont vécu
le fait d'arrêter de députés et de
plusieurs fois ils m'ont dit elle va
vous voyez c'est pas souvent que ça nous
arrive d'avoir un parlementaire qu'on
arrête qui nous dit mais c'est tout à
fait normal faites votre devoir
faites votre travail souvent il paraît
que du comment je suis parlementaire je
fais ça pour la république enfin il
parfois jusque qui me raconter ça il y
en a qui font ça a bien sûr ah ouais
ouais
oui moi j'ai jamais mis une cocarde de
ma vie oui jamais ça me choque
vous êtes estomaqué géraldine je ne le
crois pas hier pour qui est allié à un
jour dans le bureau de charles de
courson les livres sont rangés à la
règle au millimètre avec ne tolère pas
une feuille qui dépasse pas possible
alors vous allez me charles de courson
c'est donc un centriste ne faisait
remarquer il à l'arrêt à gauche
alors oui selon l'emplacement de la rai
vous l'ignoriez peut-être mais il ya un
sens qu'on parle de ça avec vous
aujourd'hui c'est un message qu'on
envoie en politique par exemple kennedy
avait l'art est à gauche
hitler avait l'arrêt à droite et oui
c'est vrai alors est-ce que chez charles
de courson ça correspondrait peut-être
un signe une symbolique occultes
ça a toujours été comme ça depuis que je
suis petit garçon il donc c'est votre
implantation ce qui fait ça oui parce
que j'ai deux épis montrez-nous
j'ai deux épis et je trouve plus facile
de la faire à gauche que la faire à
droite mais ça n'a rien à voir avec vos
points de vue politique c'est mort
à vous de rayer une récente rissala
maurice garçon voilà oui je te la mode
dans les années 30 dans les années ont
d'ailleurs je crois pas qu'ils aient
parlementaire qui est une
abbassi villani il a une vraie centriste
mais c'est très rare parce que c'est sa
date de l'entre-deux-guerres quoi il
répartit camille la récente crise alors
puisqu'on par les cheveux figurez vous
que j'ai appris qu'ils avaient il m'a
révélé qu'il a fait jadis un stage de
coloration chez l'oréal non mais oui et
alors il a pris oui vous voyez les
répéteurs dépassé et alors il a fait il
a appris à détecter les teintures les
postiches etc il est très très fort pour
ça donc j'essaie de le cuisiner
évidemment sk l'assemblée parmi les
personnalités de premier plan
est ce que certains trichent est ce
qu'il ya des cheveux teints et ce qui à
mon goût des mots
j'ai essayé de lui soutirer mais non
vous êtes en fait ils se font entendre
ça se voit ça se voit beaucoup rêver les
mots route quand même à les balancer
nous allons quoi alors je regarde moi ça
me fait rire oui moi je dis il faut
assumer à jour j'étais avec l'éphémère
secrétaire d'état madame delaunay il
s'occupait des personnes âgées et
minutieux de courson vous avez une
moumoute et je lui dis non madame la
milice chez moi tout est naturel il me
dit c'est pas possible ici et alors
elles sont par dessus elle tire belle
vidéo x et moi et je ne suis pas ta
envoyée c'est quand même là il m'a avoué
que c'était la première fois qu'il
réponde à une interview sur ce sujet un
député qui est un vrai gage budget
trompant discours il a il a demandé à
supporter de tirer parce qu'on entend
vérifier une goutte pour vérifier la
droite en baisse à banat
les amis faudra faire un livre parce que
c'est director vos anecdotes
je rappelle celui de philippe val
allegro barbaro aux édition de
l'observatoire et c'est un roman
trépidant a très vite à très bientôt sur
fpp
quant à moi je vous souhaite un
excellent week-end je vous retrouve
lundi
[Musique]